[Music]
legend has it that chocolate-chip
cookies were invented in 1930 by an
American innkeeper who ran out of
baker's chocolate she improvised by
breaking a semi-sweet chocolate bar into
small pieces instead of melting the
chocolate merely softened dotting the
cookie with chocolate chips they look
homemade and they taste homemade but
this ho is a factory each ingredient
goes into an industrial-sized mixer
starting with white sugar then brown
sugar then butter
[Music]
the mixer thoroughly blends these first
ingredients until the butter becomes
soft and creamy and the sugars are
evenly dispersed then it's time for the
headliner chocolate chips they're
semi-sweet which is a mixture of bitter
and sweet chocolate next flour followed
by baking soda to make the dough rise
and salt to add flavor the final
ingredients are whole eggs beaten
combined with vanilla made from beans
harvested in Madagascar Africa mixing
resumes until everything is well blended
which usually takes about five minutes
the company closely guards recipe
specifics but if you're curious you
could probably figure them out by
multiplying the ingredients of a home
recipe to the yield of a production
batch workers transfer the cookie dough
to a machine called the former it pushes
the dough through round eyes producing
row upon row of round pieces weighing
1.4 ounces each one of several sizes the
factory produces the factory then flash
freezes the dough rounds for sale to
foodservice customers such as
restaurants and hotels which bake the
cookies in their own kitchens the freeze
tunnel uses liquid nitrogen to create
the frigid temperature the passing dough
rounds solidify in approximately 5
minutes
exiting the freeze tunnel the dough
rounds pass under a metal detector to
ensure they don't contain any metal
particles this safety measure is
standard practice in the food industry
the packaging system is entirely
automated the first station erect the
box the second station lines it with
plastic a conveyor belt meanwhile feeds
the frozen unbaked cookies onto
automated scales once the scale hits the
per box weight feeding pauses the bottom
swings open and the cookies drop into
the box awaiting directly underneath the
next stations seal and label the boxes
which workers then load onto pallets
the pallets go into a storage freezer
where they stay until it's time to ship
them out by freezer truck to the
customer this company also sells gift
tens of cookies online and by catalog
for that market they bake the cookies
in-house workers lay out the dough
rounds two inches apart on trays lined
with parchment paper this prevents
sticking making it easy to remove the
bake cookies without breaking them the
dough rounds are nearly one and a half
inches wide by one inch high
as they bake they flatten out and double
in diameter the trays remain in the oven
for seven minutes at 300 degrees
Fahrenheit a turntable inside rotates
them so that the cookies bake evenly
throughout the tray a few cookies per
batch go to the quality control tester
who unfortunately doesn't get to conduct
the assessment by eating the samples
rather the tester measures the diameter
and height to ensure consistency in size
and chip content in the online and
catalog order assembly area workers line
the bottom part of the gift tin with the
decorative cellophane bag then they
carefully layer the correct number of
fresh cookies inside in a staggered
configuration this not only creates a
nice presentation it also prevents
damage in transit they close the bag
with a gold twist tie to seal in the
freshness close up the tin then pack it
for shipping this is how to give a gift
of homemade chocolate chip cookies
without ever setting foot in the kitchen